roommate harmony asks hey Gary do you
think it's necessary to have an outgoing
personality to be a successful
entrepreneur roommate harmony this is a
tremendous question I think there's
never been less important to be
extroverted to be a successful
entrepreneur oh I don't know just look
at every success Hawks you preneur that
everybody talks about like sucks and EV
Williams and Kevin Systrom and David
Karp you know Facebook Twitter Tumblr
and Instagram I mean Ben cildren
Pinterest I mean it's actually it's
actually the glory days of the introvert
entrepreneur because of Technology we
hurt because of sitting behind the
screen because it doesn't all happen
face-to-face anymore it's never been a
better time to do that and that's a lot
by the way always been the way it's you
know there's ways to win you know it's
about betting on strengths I do things
based on my strengths I'm an
entrepreneur that is extroverted and I
saw around myself with people and I do
that kind of stuff I put myself out
there
introverted entrepreneurs need to not
fake the funk like it'd be stupid for me
to sit behind a computer all day every
day and then that was just the way I
rolled mistake leaving the magic on the
table
equally someone who is awkward and is
like yeah my startup is thank you yeah
my startup is really like that guy or
gal is probably not the kind of person
that wants to kind of bet on their
personality and they need to sit down
all day and focus and so I think it's
betting on strengths oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe